[Musik]
quarantäne pflicht für reisende aus
großbritannien wegen der indischen
corona mutante wird das land zum
virusvarianten gebiet ab in den norden
die neue reisefreiheit sorgt für einen
touristenansturm an der küste abstieg am
letzten spieltag werder bremen muss in
der kommenden saison in die zweite liga
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten den samstags wort
hat norbert könig für sie guten abend in
großbritannien breitet sich die
vermutlich besonders gefährliche
indische variante des corona virus
weiter aus und sorgt für mehr und mehr
ansteckungen die bundesregierung stuft
nun das land als virusvarianten gebiet
ein und stoppt die einreise nach
deutschland
ab mitternacht dürfen flugzeuge busse
und bahn nur noch deutsche staatsbürger
hierher befördern
thomas garcia frankfurt flughafen freude
und familienglück glück im wahrsten
wortsinn gerade noch rechtzeitig sind
sie zur oma gekommen aus großbritannien
einen tag früher als geplant
verwandte vertraute besuchen schwierig
oder unmöglich dagegen für die die
morgen eintreffen würden
ich habe schon die gelten ab 0 uhr und
die britischen inseln als virusvarianten
gebiete heißt konkret wer nach
deutschland einreist muss hier sofort
zwei wochen in quarantäne verkürzen
lässt sich die zeit nicht aus dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium heißt es
dieser schritt ist hart für
großbritannien aber er ist notwendig um
die schnelle ausbreitung der indischen
variante in deutschland zu verhindern
bislang wurden hierzulande erst gut 140
fälle registriert in großbritannien 3400
die gefahren der der entchen sub
variante b 61 600 17.2 liegt darin dass
sich zum einen sehr stark ansteckend ist
und zu mal an dass der impfschutz
möglicherweise nicht ganz so effektiv
ist
dennoch wirken die vakzine auch gegen
diese variante als barriere gegen neue
infektionen gegen eine neue
wille dazu diana zimmermann in london
diana weiß man denn welcher anteil der
ansteckungen auf die irische
virusvariante zurückgeht
ja das sind inzwischen wohl mehr als 50
prozent der ansteckung die gesamtzahl
der neuinfektionen täglich hier ist mit
2700 zwar immer noch relativ niedrig
allerdings doch zehn prozent höher als
vergangene woche
ob das darauf zurückzuführen ist dass
die indische variante ebenso viel
ansteckender zu sein scheint oder doch
auch darauf dass ihr seit montag pubs
und restaurants wieder geöffnet sind und
die briten ziemlich ausgelassen davon
gebrauch machen dass man sich in
innenräumen treffen darf das ist noch
nicht klar
klar scheint zu sein dass die impfstoffe
an wirksamkeit nur wenig einbüßten
gegenüber der indischen variante und
boris johnson möchte deswegen auch
bisher noch nicht von seinem geplanten
öffnungs schritt nächsten öffnungs
schritt am 21 juni abrücken
die briten finden das natürlich keine
gute nachricht dass deutschland zu macht
die meisten sind allerdings gut damit
getröstet dass spanien ab montag für
alle britischen touristen die arme
öffnet und sie ganz ohne zwang zur
quarantäne ins land lässt vielen dank
für die einordnung aus london
anderswo wird an der grenze leichter
etwa für alle die zwischen frankreich
und deutschland pendeln
ab mitternacht ist dafür kein corona
testen erforderlich bislang brauchen
grenzgänger an fast allen übergängen
nach deutschland alle 48 stunden einen
neuen test für andere reisende fällt die
quarantäne pflicht weg allerdings nur
wenn sie geimpft getestet oder genesen
sind
grund sind die stark sinkenden
infektionszahlen in frankreich bei
urlaubsreisen ins ausland soll ja bald
der digitale impfpass helfen
dafür müssen aber erst einmal die daten
aus dem gelben im heft digitalisiert
werden
dafür stünden die meisten der rund
18.000 apotheken bereit sagt heute der
apothekerverband nordrhein
man entwickele derzeit unter anderem mit
ibm eine plattform um pünktlich mitte
juli starten zu können
das pfingstwochenende nutzten einige um
endlich mal wieder rauszukommen
eines der bundesländer von bayern bis
schleswig-holstein die ihre unterkünfte
unter auflagen für touristen geöffnet
haben voraussetzungen eine stabile
incidents unter 100 in einigen wenigen
ländern bleiben die unterkünfte
geschlossen oder es gibt übergangsregeln
wie klappt es mit dem urlaub in der
pandemie glas thomsen berichtet von der
nordsee sturm liegen elf grad das sphinx
wird auf sucht die sonst zu dieser zeit
zurück ich gefüllten strände fast leer
dennoch nicht nur die kein glück sondern
auch die ganz normalen urlaub frische
luft dass das wichtigste und ihr
investor wird dabei geben wetter schön
und das dachten sich wohl viele urlauber
nach der langen kroner zeit die straßen
auf sylt bei dem durchwachsenen wetter
entsprechend rappelvoll buchungslage auf
sylt und an der küste insgesamt lässt
viele aus der tourismusbranche
zuversichtlich auf die saison blicken
die insel ist oliver pfingsten und auch
der sommer wird auf sylt gut werden da
bin ich ziemlich sicher ähnlich stark
der ansturm an der niedersächsischen
küste am fährhafen zu der insel langeoog
bildeten sich lange schlangen
es wurden sogar zusätzliche fähren in
betrieb genommen auf corona getestet und
mit registriert wird umfangreich das
gesundheitsamt nordfriesland hat am
montag festgestellt dass von 240
positiven schnelltests nur 3 durch einen
pcr test bestätigt wurden dennoch die
ansage vom kreis das aufladen zu
pfingsten besonders streng kontrolliert
würden
morgen soll dann auch das wetter beim
start in die urlaubssaison an der
norddeutschen küste noch ein bisschen
mehr mitspielt
immer mehr menschen bekommen die zweite
im spritze aktuell gibt es sogar
deutlich mehr zeit als erstimpfungen zur
gesundheitsminister sparen
mehr als elf millionen menschen sind
vollständig geimpft und die korona
zahlen sinken weiter
das rk ii meldet 7082 neue infektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden 812 weniger als
vergangenen samstag
170 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents sinkt leicht auf 66,8 in
fünf bundesländern liegt die incidents
derzeit sogar unter 50 mehr zahlen und
grafiken finden sie in der zdf- heute-
app auch wie es in ihrer region aussieht
eine interaktive karte zum durchklicken
unser nächstes thema der nahostkonflikt
da hat sich us-präsident beiden klar für
eine zwei staaten lösung ausgesprochen
sie sei die einzige antwort im konflikt
zwischen israel und den palästinensern
die usa seien bereit den wiederaufbau im
gazastreifen zu unterstützen
es müsse aber verhindert werden dass
sich die hamas neu bewaffnet in
deutschland hat kanzlerin merkel
deutliche kritik geübt an
antisemitischen vorfällen bei
demonstrationen gegen die israelische
palästinenser politik in ihrer
videobotschaft sagte sie wer hass gegen
juden auf die straßen trage wer
volksverhetzende beleidigende begriffe
wieder markus groß berichtet
solidarität mit palästina hunderte
teilnehmer bei einer demo in berlin
kreuzberg anti israelische parolen wie
man sie aus den vergangenen tagen kennt
aber auch aufrufe zu einem friedlichen
miteinander
die neue lage in nahost verändert die
stimmung bei einer kundgebung am
potsdamer platz auch zustimmung zur
waffenruhe im gaza-konflikt während wir
reden wir möchten in frieden und
freiheit leben wir können nicht so
weiterleben so eine komplette sollten
sie irgendwann oder wie gestoppt auch in
hamburg proteste am nachmittag mit einem
autokorso machen hunderte menschen auf
die situation der palästinenser im
gazastreifen aufmerksam
der protestzug führt auch an einem
jüdischen bildungszentrum vorbei der
korso verläuft friedlich
bilder der solidarität gibt es in
leipzig vor dem rathaus setzten gestern
abend hunderte menschen ein zeichen
gegen antisemitismus
grund für die kundgebung waren
judenfeindliche vorfälle bei einigen
demonstrationen in der letzten woche in
der nacht hatte es in berlin einen
angriff auf einen 41 jährigen juden
gegeben der eine kippa trug wie die
polizei mitteilte wurde der mann in
schöneberg von drei unbekannten
beleidigt einer von ihnen schlug ihm
dann mit der faust ins gesicht der
verletzte musste im krankenhaus
behandelt werden
die ermittlungen laufen zwei
demonstrationen der sogenannten
querdenker in berlin hatten gerichte ja
verboten
trotzdem versammelten sich heute mehrere
hundert menschen im zentrum der stadt
überwiegend ohne abstand und masken die
polizei löste die versammlungen auf
erteilte platzverweise und sperrte den
bereich ums brandenburger tor großräumig
ab in thüringen hat die polizei das haus
des dortigen afd vorsitzenden björn
höcke durchsucht hintergrund sind
ermittlungen wegen volksverhetzung der
vorwurf höcke soll flüchtlinge in
sozialen netzwerken als kriminelle
stigmatisiert haben
schon im dezember war seine immunität
für das verfahren aufgehoben worden
argentinien erlebt gerade den
schlimmsten moment seit beginn der
pandemie sagt präsident fernandez und
schwört sein land auf einen zweiten
harten lockdown 1
tatsächlich liegt die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektion derzeit bei rund 36.000 bei
nur rund halb so viel einwohnern wie in
deutschland
täglich sterben etwa 490 menschen an
oder mit dem virus jetzt kurz vor beginn
des winters wird das land also wieder
runtergefahren christ afrika halt
es wirkt fast wie eine inszenierung doch
es ist die triste realität auf dem
friedhof der stadt pilar in der nähe von
buenos aires die zum sinnbild wird für
das einsame ende der kogit opfer und die
hilflosigkeit derer die noch leben
wir befinden uns im krieg sagen die
totengräber und drohen mit streik weil
auch sie noch nicht geimpft sind
wir haben angst und deshalb wollen wir
den impfstoff für alle
wir hätten gerne noch ein paar jahre zu
leben wegen der schleppenden
impfkampagne die vor allem auf den
umstrittenen russischen stoff sputnik
setzt steht die argentinische mitte
links regierung in der kritik die
wirtschaft leidet unter einer
anhaltenden krise ein erneuter harter
lockdown dürfte diese verschärfen
doch aufgrund der korona zahlen sieht
präsident fernandez keine alternative
mehr
die menschen dürfen sich nur noch im
umfeld ihres wohnortes bewegen und das
nur zwischen sechs uhr morgens um sechs
uhr abends hilferufe kommen vor allem
aus den krankenhäusern in buenos aires
ärzte berichten von einem dramatischen
anstieg der sterblichkeitsrate auf den
intensivstationen es fehle an betten
personal und geld
es gibt in argentinien keine
gesundheitspolitik die die pandemie
bremst das einzige was argentinien tut
ist die leute generell und ineffektiv zu
isolieren
das personal im gesundheitswesen fühlt
sich allein gelassen
krankenschwestern demonstrieren und
gedenken ihrer toten kolleginnen auch in
argentinien deckt corona gnadenlos die
strukturellen und politischen defizite
auf das ganze land leidet hier bei uns
machen die korona zahlen ja lockerungen
möglich nur fast alle freizeitpark sind
noch zu ausnahmen sind der heide park in
soltau und seit diesem wochenende der
europa park in rust mit den
besucherzahlen lassen sie es dort
langsam angehen man will erst mal die
abläufe testen und erkenntnisse gewinnen
die auch anderen netzen könnten sein
glas berichtet der rote teppich ist
ausgerollt zur wiedereröffnung nach
einem halben jahr zwangspause rein
dürfen nur wenige tausend besucher pro
tag getestet genießen oder geimpft beim
anstehen und fahren gilt masken pflicht
vielen besuchern sind diese maßnahmen
auch wichtig das leben kehrt zurück ein
stück normalität und wir haben zusammen
mit den kindern auf diesen tag
hingefiebert die wiedereröffnung nur
möglich weil die inzidenz im landkreis
seit tagen unter 100 liegt und im rahmen
eines modellprojekts unter
wissenschaftlicher begleitung die tests
strategie danach weiß wie die
ablaufprozesse gehen wie es im umfeld
läuft das alles wollen wir erkenntnisse
erzielen um es dann für die gesamte
branche beim nächsten öffnung schritten
auch nutzbar machen zu können
die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
monatelangen schließungen sind massiv
nicht nur beim europa-park
deutschlandweit sind die meisten
freizeitparks noch zu die branche stehe
mit dem rücken zur wand sagt der
freizeitpark verband hält das
infektionsrisiko in parks unter freiem
himmel für gering
nichtsdestotrotz sind in ländern wie
bayern nordrhein-westfalen
rheinland-pfalz alle alle außen
attraktionen geöffnet haben wieder eine
betriebserlaubnis einzig freizeitparks
sind ausgenommen
das ist nicht zu akzeptieren in baden
württemberg macht der europa tat nun den
anfang hofft dass die inzidenz nicht
wieder über 100 steigt und dass sie
weitermachen können
zum sparen da muss werder bremen runter
in die zweite bundesliga und das kommt
nicht gerade überraschenden aber absolut
nicht wer nur einen punkt holte in den
letzten zehn spielen
der darf sich wirklich nicht beschweren
der zweite abstieg der grün weißen ist
also besiegelt während sich köln noch in
die relegation rettet verliert der sv
werder daheim mit 2 4 gegen
mönchengladbach
selbst die ungestüme unterstützung der
anhänger ohne auf abstandsregeln zu
achten sie verhindert das
schlimmstmögliche ende dieses
nachmittags am weser-stadion nicht wer
da im tal der tränen abgestiegen nur
sieben siege in dieser saison der letzte
anfang märz 300 kilometer südwestlich
zwar noch kein happy end aber immerhin
ein happy teilerfolg für den ersten fc
köln
[Applaus]
wie es die fans wünschen die aufstiegs
helden kämpfen und siegen 1 zu 0 über
schalke dank eines späten kopfballtores
von sebastian bono köln nun in der
relegation mit dem dritten der zweiten
liga bielefeld rettet sich mit einem 2 0
sieg in stuttgart trauer dagegen in
bremen nach 41 jahren ist werder nun
wieder zweitklassig bundesliga
geschichte schreibt robert lewandowski
der torjäger löscht mit seinem 41
saisontreffer den alten rekord von gerd
müller in der neunzigsten minute trifft
der pole zum 5 2 endstand gegen augsburg
das zwei zuviel gegen gladbach besiegelt
also wer das abstieg köln darf hoffen
durch das 1 0 gegen schalke
bielefeld bleibt drin 2 zu 0 in
stuttgart
union berlin startet international 2 zu
1 gegen leipzig wolfsburg mainz 23
dortmund leverkusen 3 2 1 frankfurt
freiburg ebenfalls 3 2 1 und hoffenheim
gegen hertha bsc 2 2 1 die bayern wollen
den 31 den titel 13 punkte vor leipzig
dortmund beinahe noch zweiter wolfsburg
auf platz vier
frankfurt leverkusen in der europa
league union berlin traf in der neuen
konferenz league mitspielen
mönchengladbach nicht unten oft köln
also auf die relegation werder bremen
steigt ab in begleitung von schalke 04
dem schlechtesten team seit einführung
der drei-punkte-regel das aktuelle
sportstudio um 23 uhr natürlich mit der
bundesliga zu gast ist katja kraus die
sich vorstellen kann erste dfb
präsidentin zu werden
zweiter auftritt bei der
weltmeisterschaft in lettland und
zweiter klarer sieg zum ersten mal seit
14 jahren gewinnt die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft der männer bei einer
wm gegen null
zu lächeln fällt den deutschen spielern
leicht bei dieser wm noch eine spur
besser als beim erfolg über italien geht
das team ende des ersten drittels durch
matthias plachta verdient in führung
bundestrainer schülerheim in denkerpose
sieht im zweiten drittel eine dominante
deutsche mannschaft die ihre
überlegenheit in drei weiteren toren
ausdruck schenkt wobei dem 19 jährigen
lukas reichel der wohl spektakulärste
treffer der partie gelingt nach dem
einzigen gegentreffer der norweger runde
dem abschluss drittel leonberg man den
deutschen erfolg zum 5 1 endstand ab mit
schon 14 tore nach erst zwei spielen
kann sich das deutsche team nun mit
gestärktem selbstvertrauen auf das match
am montagabend gegen kanada vorbereiten
damit ein bisschen schwerer
das tanken arbeit viele touristen
attraktionen sind noch immer
menschenleer und tiere erobern sich das
terra am machu picchu in peru gab es
jetzt ungewöhnlichen besuch zwei anderen
bären wo sich normalerweise tausende
menschen drängen erkunden die
bärenmutter und ihr junges in aller ruhe
die verwaiste ruinenstadt die beiden
werden auch als brillenbären bezeichnet
und sind eine gefährdete art in
doppelter hinsicht also was ganz
besonderes
tja würde den inkas vielleicht gefallen
über pfingsten lässt der wind etwas nach
und in manchen regionen wird es sogar
sonnig und warm
wo es dagegen ungemütlich wechselhaft
bleibt sagt uns gleich katja hoffe das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka und das heute journal
heute gegen viertel vor elf und wir sind
morgen wieder da um sich einen schönen
start ins verlängerte wochenende jazz
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren wie die
tiefs ziehen bestimmt der jet das ist
ein stark wind band in etwa zwölf
kilometer höhe einmal dargestellt durch
diese orangen pfeile schon seit längerem
10 die tiefe und westen oder von
nordwesten heran und biegen dann über
mitteleuropa richtung skandinavien ab
zwischendurch ist aber auch mal platz
für klaren himmel heute nacht gibt es
den hier zwischen der elbe und dem main
in süddeutschland regnet es noch
kräftiger sonst gibt es noch einige
schauer bei einem starken bis
stürmischen west bis südwestwind
die temperaturen sinken heute nacht auf
9 bis 5 grad und morgen bleibt es an der
nordsee sehr kühl
da sind das nur so 12 bis 13 grad sonst
werden 14 bis 17 grad erreichen am
oberrhein geht's bis 19 grad drauf der
vormittag ist noch meist trüb häufig
regnet es und selten zeigt sich schon
die sonne das ändert sich am nachmittag
besonders zwischen dem oberrhein und dem
allgäu da sehen sie die sonne zum teil
strahlt es gibt allerdings auch noch mal
kräftigere schauer oder gewitter
in diesem dreieck hannover berlin erfurt
am pfingstmontag gibt es dann im
südosten viel sonnenschein und im
südlichen brandenburg klettern die werte
bis 23 grad danach geht es wechselhaft
weiter fröhlich pfingsten